good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-896
[Music]
housed at site 17 scp-896 meters sell
furnished with a bed a nightstand two
bookcases complete with medical
textbooks and a writing desk all of
which were originally furnished by the
subject subject is disallowed from
contact with any mechanical artificial
or otherwise nonliving SCPs
as well as any foundation equipment
under any circumstances except during
approved surgical procedures any
observation of scp-896
as CP 892 the medical bay for any
surgery scheduled in advance with
consent of any level for personnel are
in emergency conditions which may arise
requiring those facilities to be
otherwise in use staff wishing to
introduce an object to scp-896 plenary
measures up to transfer to a new site in
order to promote better behavior and
cooperation with containment procedures
it is permissible to occasionally
provide a CP 890 with a piece of
intentionally damaged equipment for
repair description scp-896 eped for its
eyes which are a chromatic appear in
grey personnel should avoid mentioning
this as it seems to cause subject some
distress subject is typically dressed in
surgical scrubs green in color and is
often seen wearing a surgical cap and
mask when given a set of standard
medical tools as CP 890 is able to
operate on machines as though they were
composed of living flesh testing
confirms that any medical supplies used
by a CP 890 will have this effect
subject appears to be capable of
operating on any machine requiring some
kind of energy to operate whether
powered by clockwork steam electricity
or during an operation objects appeared
to be transmuted into living tissue
including skin bone musculature and
other organ systems as well as blood and
nervous tissue
similarly tissue may be removed and
discarded but will not revert to its
original mechanical
DNA testing on discarded tissue samples
reveals that tissue transmutation
appears to be related to a position
within the object such as the outermost
material becoming like skin regardless
of the type of material observation by
foundation medical personnel indicates
that the organs present in the object do
not correspond to known organs in living
animals the results of scp-896
seemed to yield fairly mixed results in
approximately 20% of all cases the
object may die on the table rendering it
inoperable
if such an outcome occurs no amount of
repairs even by technicians specifically
trained to maintain and repair the item
will ever return it to working condition
it can however be disassembled and used
for parts in some cases complications
may arise from an operation causing
either unexpected or undesirable
operation in the object these can
usually be corrected by a CPA 90 with
one or more additional procedures in all
cases objects must heal for a period of
time before becoming fully operable
again how long this takes
appears to be dependent on how many
moving parts the device has with
solid-state electronics recovering more
quickly than complicated mechanical
objects recovery time is significantly
shorter than expected for similarly
complex procedures performed on humans
typically taking only a few hours
however more complicated devices may
require a few days to fully recover as
CP 892 lat
objectives are in need of its services
before performing surgery as CP 891
interview the object video logs show a
typical although one-sided surgery
consult where scp-896
and the nature of its problem
afterward scp-896 subject displays an
apparent apathy towards humans and other
living creatures stating it cannot
operate on animals because it is a
surgeon not a veterinarian scp-896
for the murder of on mark 23 subject was
performing an emergency surgery to save
the life of a pacemaker killing in whom
it was installed in the process
subsequent testing revealed that the
pacemaker is once again fully
operational see interview log 891 for
more information
this is interview log 891 date March
2020 interviewee scp-896
playing log now please state your name
for the record mister what are you doing
in mark a week ago I was performing
surgery on a patient completely so
operation was a complete success I do
not understand how did you become aware
of the patient means a mass of flesh
surrounding my patient it certainly
means a procedure a bit more tedious but
otherwise I've seen many such cases
that you kill them I did nothing of the
sort
my patient not only survived but
recovered quite nicely if you're
referring to the mass surroundings a
patient I lived it in place as a patient
was I suggested it to be removed but as
the patient was adamant to be left in
place okay that about does it for today
thank you very much for listening if
indeed you still are and you're all
dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Desmond Hoskins Dustin
Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov Tiber
ball and dr. mortis thank you all so
much for your support is greatly
appreciated if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos on some other cool stuff as well
as it patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
[Music]
you